hi I'm Chelsea chupp product manager for
AIML and HPC
thanks for joining me today as we review
Google Cloud's HPC toolkit
let's get started
[Music]
at Google we've recognized that the hvc
community uses a wide array of
Technologies including offerings from
partners and custom in-house Solutions
setting up iterating upon configurations
and tearing down these clusters can be
quite challenging
it can also be difficult to effectively
combine all these Technologies
especially if the cloud is an unfamiliar
environment our mission for the cloud
HPC toolkit is to make it easy for our
users to deploy repeatable HPC
environments which are optimized for HPC
workloads based on Google Cloud's proven
best practices
the toolkit provides a simplified
experience for first-time cloud and
terraform users while maintaining the
ability to configure and customize your
cluster for your specific needs
the toolkit is a free and open source
tool so you only need to pay for the
resources that are provisioned let's
talk about what is in the HPC toolkit
the HBC toolkit consists of a set of
blueprints which Define the HPC cluster
or system and calls a set of modules
which is used to deploy actual Cloud
infrastructure such as compute
networking and storage resources
one way to think of it is that blueprint
calls the modules to be able to create
the infrastructure that you need in the
modules we support schedulers such as
slurm HD Condor and Google Cloud batch
with more partner offerings to come
for storage we support file store Intel
daus ddn exascaler luster and local SSD
and persistent disk
other modules support key
functionalities such as SPAC Dell Omnia
and Cloud monitoring
for a complete list visit the hvc
toolkit GitHub repo
you can also extend the toolkit's
functionality by using the modules
authored outside of the toolkit either
from a git repository or a local
directory
the HPC toolkit modules are the building
blocks used to define your HPC
environment these modules Define
high-level components such as parallel
file systems workload managers and
software stacks and networking
infrastructure
the HBC toolkit comes pre-packaged with
a growing list of core and owned
Community modules
these modules are designed to work
together to make it easy to combine
partner Technology Solutions with and on
your Google Cloud infrastructure
now let's talk about the blueprints
the blueprint is your design plan
referencing a list of modules and how
they're all interconnected
a blueprint is the only part that you
need to understand to deploy your HPC
cluster
it's a simple text configuration file or
a yaml file that composes your entire
HPC environment including the
infrastructure and software
the hvc toolkit provides a set of
supported and tested standard blueprints
you can use These Blueprints as is or
customize them based upon your specific
use case and requirements
to actually run the HPC toolkit we use
ghpc engine to convert a blueprint to a
deployment folder which can then be
deployed onto Google Cloud
once deployed you can then easily add on
monitoring and analytics to know exactly
how your cluster or system is performing
the deployment folder will contain all
of the underlying terraform Packer and
scripts needed to deploy a complete hvc
environment that has been wired together
as described by your blueprint
it can be tracked as source code and
distributed the blueprint of the HPC
toolkit describes a complex environment
in just a simple text or yaml file
by only having to modify the yaml file
it saves you having to Wade through
thousands of lines of code to make
changes or modifications
and only a few line the blueprint file
will generate the necessary scripts and
modules to create your fully functioning
HPC environment the hvc toolkit creates
standard repeatable deployment templates
saving your team time to achieve Optimal
Performance
it also eases the learning curve if your
team is new to Cloud
as a free open source tool extensibility
is a key design principle to enable the
technologies that you require
we look forward to working with you and
hearing of your success thanks for
listening check out our other videos or
cloud.google.com
hpc-toolkit to learn more
[Music]
foreign